[Music]  tensions are mounting on the  israeli-egyptian border if thousands of  soldiers are massing the fear remains  that war could break out at any time in  three days Egypt will attack Israel  this Israeli embassy how may I direct  your call  Israeli ambassador please I have  information of interested Israeli  intelligence services I want to watch  every move you mention find out whose  side he's on the son of the great Nasser  if you do something that you have to do  something bigger  [Applause]  why are you helping history because  millions of innocent people will die on  both sides that's why you can't leave to  me I'm trying to save our family no one  you're known as the angel I like it  you need to learn to handle your acid  going to save Israel  you want to save the life of your  soldier  you  you